why probably felt like you know what I
suicide you get my pieces out I'm gonna
win this game okay I got two bishops I
got a strong passed pawn on c6 but he
perhaps miss this idea and
underestimated it so now I want to make
sure you don't miss it
[Music]
welcome everyone to the pastor's
paradise class soon this class will be
just doing lots of different partners
we'll start out with something not so
difficult we medium difficulty and then
we're gonna want to the harder ones and
you know we have some very strong
players are here today so we're gonna do
probably some hard positions okay
so this position is you know the game
between I'm not sure the player with the
white pieces but the player with black
pieces is a Ukrainian Grandmaster Cora
booth so it's a very strong player and
he's black and this is played in a
German League Bundesliga and here is
white to play and win as you can see
black is threatening to take on c2 here
with his bishop or queen so not only you
gotta defend against that threat you
also have to come up with your own idea
here to create contra place so how did
the player vs Erick we're soaring I'm
not familiar with that player is managed
to manage to win this game because the
threats they look they look very very
dangerous the threats you know so what
do you see here but you have to see the
whole thing okay so I fish in particular
you always raise your hand but you got
to see the entire combination before you
go okay
so when you say I'm ready the whole
concept or the whole thing you gotta
tell me okay
in this particular one it's it's five
moves calculation okay five moves guys
are sure are June 5 moves got a blade
everything in your head that that's how
you're gonna do in a tournament ok five
moves just less
okay Arjuna have the entire thing the
whole thing okay I'm gonna give a chance
to our gym see if you can do it Arjuna
is very strong player one of the
strongest players in Saint Louis yeah
young young from the young players okay
so what can I do
excellent our June 1 point
excellent job ok so very good very good
job ok who else saw it this idea 3 moves
in this is tough yeah this is because
the threads you win a rock you know but
at rest look at the threads here yeah
Queen before check is there Quincy to
check is that it looks at it looks very
scary here it looks like doing a trick
minute here actually you know made it
yourself Ashish but our journeys getting
stronger so he saw a one move deeper
look these six sacrifice to change
everything to his advantage okay to win
this so that's how this pair played to
win against 2700 Grandmaster Cora both
okay next position we're gonna do one
more one more medium okay
medium difficulty this is a game between
I like to do with games you know and
grandmasters the top grandmasters when
when I have a chance so this is a game
between mama da rocha career mama Dee
are off number three player in the world
from Azerbaijan against a former world
champion Ruslan ponomaryov from Ukraine
so I've played both of these players
very strong top players why to play and
win here here you have to play like mama
D other than keep in mind he saw this in
a rapid game he was a rapid game that he
saw all this okay so see if you can do
it howdy mama DRF game okay mommy dr.oz
versus ponomaryov you gotta see the
whole thing Adi okay you have the whole
thing Ashish she she's confident let's
give a chance to everybody else to think
little bit
I'll ask you first okay but let's give a
chance to others to solve it on their
own because when you solve it on your
own you remember the idea much better
our Jun is ready
drop it game rapid game he managed to
see this very impressive
Ashish you sure are not sure anymore you
Fisher okay
okay any other no okay
minute remaining minute remaining then
I'll ask Ashish first okay
Arjun be ready if he's wrong then you're
gonna get your chance okay
if
all right Ashish there we go let's go
d7 it seems that for a moment what is he
doing he's sacrificing the pawn I take
it Ashish Bishop a4 discovery check if
the King comes up you take the bishop so
he has to go backwards on e7 and then
group b7 pin it to win it
and now the most important thing the
bishop on d1 is covering the a
Foursquare okay so that's why you put
the bishop on a4 to cover the d1 square
and then you pick up the bishop not
super hard it's a three move combination
but again you have to connect your
pieces together that's why I did Bishop
a4 not this should be five right we
should be five looks good too but no he
plays Bishop a4 connecting covering the
d1 square and then he's got the pin on
it as well any questions
moving forward okay that's how he
managed to win him again Mahmud Yadav
versus ponomaryov all right let's go to
the hard section okay we jump from
medium to more difficulty section this
is a game between international master
Ampang giovanni from canada against the
master from cuba bruising so very very
strong a massive bruising it's black
here and something went wrong for
Grandmaster bruising here and he's in a
difficult position
he gets pal Johnny and there is a
possibility to strike here there is a
chance there is a possibility to strike
you just have to look for it okay found
Johnny white against a very strong
Grandmaster who is probably 200 points
at least higher than him
bruising okay what we got here
very impressive very very impressive I
have to say this combination for five
moves calculation harder much harder
than the other ones okay
but this International master managed to
say it during the game without knowing
that there is something there
you guys have an advantage because you
know there is something already there
that's why you have this position right
here so you just have to figure out how
he finds the idea to strike how he finds
this idea to strike okay so one player
has it let's give a few more minutes few
more minutes to think this is the
hardest one so far
but for most once you see the first four
moves then it's good one thing it's a
little dangerous the background
situation you know there is a background
issues here for white so there are some
background issues okay all right Bishop
III who saw this move who thought about
this move you thought about it okay
Arjuna thought about it okay this is
called deflection also known as the
decoy sacrifice okay
have to take it no questions 96 look at
that idea discover you're talking and if
you do any kind of interposing here it's
not gonna help because of double check
goes in a corner shipmate perfect so
well it is what it is have to take
perfect now the bishop is hanging the
knight is hanging Queen before only move
attacking the rook with a background
check mate ideas at some point rook e8
precisely we're not afraid of losing the
bishop because the Queen can no longer
threaten or anything after that through
Katie played Bishop a6 now it's still
not over it's still not over
yes it's quite possible that you know
bruising was counting on this movie now
to survive this attack may be on winner
but strong play game from punch Ronny
okay sorry take we have this well this
is only one pawn it's not so not enough
not so much
yeah climb a tree maybe yeah so let's
think here let's pause and think here
let's figure out a way not to let that
night to get out can we figure out a way
not to let that might come out let him
stay there on b8 again if we had our
left here we don't we're gonna be even
discussing this it would have been
easier winning but we don't have the
look unfortunately so we have to come up
with a strong play here
this would be five ideas maybe at some
point
yeah well that's Bishop a fool doesn't
Isis nah sheesh yeah silent work we
gotta figure out a way to keep that
night there somehow keep that night
there huh
a4 Bravo yes a for keeping that night
there now he takes you take it's a
strange position he cannot take you
because I hate to say no if takes sorry
you take on ba so he takes here
threatening background checkmate now on
d1 and now what kind of lifts we need
what kind of looked win it normally if
he has a dark square Bishop Arjuna g3
your lifts should be opposite color
remember everybody opposite color so so
this could be a big problem if you don't
play jittery here now it takes and white
white went on to win the game because
threatening mate sorry 13 to win the
bishop you probably have to do this and
can take the pawn it's still technical
it's it's still technical you know but
he went on he position is winning at
least according to you know to this you
know so so takes so Queen D for Queen e7
I mean it looks kind of lost yeah seven
we need to pick up a couple of poems now
yeah to pass it yeah yeah okay so that's
the idea to see okay so let me just show
you let's say you play jittery now it's
just interesting yeah this could be a
problem now because check come up now it
takes
and imagine same position there there
there are like checks there are a lot of
checks out there you know that you have
to worry about now so this this wouldn't
be the same like even the same position
right we discuss look at that check now
look at that check again lots of
difficulties are necessary difficulties
that we don't need so again we come down
to the lift should be opposite color of
opponents Bishop if opponent doesn't
have a bishop that is different okay but
if he has a dark square bishop your loop
should be white if he has a light square
bishop your lift should be dark very
good moving forward that was very good
okay
that was a difficult one bishop a tree
not a easy move to see here that
requires good calculation to see this
move okay
and the consequence is of course you
probably saw this you know but he was a
tall queen before and usually after
clean before you feel safe you like okay
this is good but move rook e8 bishop a
six a four that's that's special okay
this is the excellent example okay
excellent example white to play and win
this is Olivares not familiar with him
so so probably international olivera's
this is a strong 2700 grandmasters Sasha
Kieran from India
Sasha Kieran Krishna so white somehow
the the low ranked opponent got a
beautiful position is got this
dominating dark squares here but how to
find a finish how can we find a finish
here to defeat a such a strong player
here like Sasha Kieran let me see if he
did it he did it yes he managed to find
it and very very impressive ideas he
found this is one of those positions
when you get into these complications
you have to look you have to keep
looking for keep sacking you know
okay yes Arjuna Knight takes d5
try ticks 96 takes
yeah but I mean
okay so we're back with this queen
eight-six I'll go check
I have okafor here and I don't think
this works our gym but but you you will
probably want to find out why yeah okay
King eh sir this is fine
and then just trade Queens
and it take
first of all let's think let's think
let's think come on
fantastic but it's it's a lot longer
than the the the the initial sacrifice
okay that's correct
opening up the position I capture check
so he has to go here yeah because if you
go here check check my yeah yes so he
has to go here
fantastic pancakes
draw no
Hey
yes he comes back unfortunately I think
Queen h6 and Queens your cellmate well
almost I have so much material that I
can you know I have a lot of extra
materials so now don't rush don't rush
don't rush I mean it's probably good but
I have six first
now don't rush
[Music]
now he takes he takes only five you know
no I know here right yeah you could but
then he takes with the king it's not so
clear you know too many threats yeah and
now because now here you threaten
discovery checks winning the Queen so it
goes here beautiful isn't it
and that's how he managed to defeat it
his opponent okay excellent
nice work everybody got it should we do
it again alright so it starts off with
take take take take
Queeny tree check check check and mate
got it white to play and win this is sad
Vikas off and the news
sattva Kossoff by news let me make sure
the position that the cause of ski no
it's a sad zukovsky actually not Sadako
Sikorsky not familiar with him but the
news is a grandmaster from Hungaria
white plane will not so difficult this
one but it's nice they have one player
who has it let's give a chance to the
our young players as well to see if they
can do it it's reg think tactics tactics
are hh4 Quinn d8 Quinn d8 Suresh I
Suresh
sheesh Tinka sheesh are the Incas what
can you do no man go specify specified
97 he says correct
look at that move check and the rook is
on prey here so has to do captura
now h4 you say give me that Quinn where
is the Queen go in now guys can I go -
here take here take here take here we
have 97 if I go here what you have
g5 Bravo check
now it's very important not to take this
because you allow the prepared okay
don't allow the Pripet you take if check
you just go here no problem okay if
Queen is six then you can take the rook
all right that that wins for white
so after G five after H four how about
this idea
Knight takes F five
night III Queenie - he captures we
capture he captures and this is a
winning position I mean it's not
immediately winning but it's it's you're
gonna win this Queen is stronger okay so
not easy not easy to see this okay I can
tell that it you know it especially but
player with the white pieces took the
time into it and consider the options
and came up with it it's very important
to start out with night D because that's
the only year the only way you can have
h for support otherwise you're not gonna
have the H for support okay so very
important to start out with this check
when you have the H for support to do it
so take once again guys let's go our Jun
Ashish quickly Noddy
you remove the Queen so you can do what
okay
and now the key move excellent
yes now if context we have a mate if
Queen takes we take this guy so he goes
check now stretch
check where do you go stretch G - G -
check that's it that's it takes Bishop
takes and if it takes cup tuna and it
goes here h3 and you bring the bishop
back home
you bring the bishop back home okay nice
work nice very nice difficult difficult
stuff okay moving forward okay good work
right here guys calculation okay a lot
of calculation needed here this is a
game between Li Chiao one of the top
Chinese grandmasters against Hungarian
Grandmaster Zoltan al maseeh so let's
see if you got this okay okay every day
and ready block to move let's go
complications yeah it looks like lots of
complications you know to bishops it
white probably felt like you know what I
suicide you get my pieces out I'm gonna
win this game okay I got two bishops I
got a strong passed pawn on c6 but he
perhaps missed this idea and
underestimated it so now I want to make
sure you don't miss it
block to play and win play like a twenty
seven this is a the Battle of the 2700
okay this is a strong battle okay rook
c5 here Queen takes e5 Bishop f1 we
should be one messy messy King c2 I try
to run can see two I try to run enough
okay who has it who you think he thinks
has it our June first chance we give it
to our son Luke f5 playing like a 2,700
Grandmaster Bravo
double exclamation mark now he played c7
but what's going on with this move it
seems like I can just play this and get
away with it
rook FC five stunning reply he takes d3
check
he takes thank you very much for the
Queen
look at that discovery need d3 discovery
check picking up that Queen okay
excellent
so Rock f5 c7 he goes pushes now what do
you do
quintics of one is probably very good
but when you see a good move you look
for a better one remembers a monorail
last year yeah so what did he say here
okay this idea guys
well Rock f1 Ashish this is already 26
shush this is already you sure about
this okay
it's happening hey my pond is still
there it's still existing there okay
it's not gonna be a piece of cake here
to win this position I'm probably gonna
win but let's go back okay you can win
this in one move one move you can win
this which move how about get a pan
wedge is it possible to get a pan wedge
here of course d3 threatening rook f1 or
queen f1 so he has to take check thank
you and he no longer can please see it
because his queen is not there anymore
and now we're winning this okay
Queen here Quincy five is good Queen b6
is good let's take that time to take it
and get rid of that pawn on the seventh
rank okay very nice good job Archon
goods good start okay good start with
the rook f5 this is the kind of movie
you want to see rook air-five it's like
you forcing upon a king to come here and
then you get this move in with a nice
flick in flicking d3 discovery check
attacking it got it and the last one
okay
the last position for today
so this example will show you how to
counter-attack okay
when it looks like opponent is attacking
you then you turn the things around and
you can't attack and you win black to
plain win
this is Grandmaster pants Alya from
Georgia Grandmaster Tomsula I played
this game and won okay let's see if you
can do that another minute for everybody
to think and calculate you have to see
the whole thing Ashish the whole concept
okay
not just to start of the combination the
finish as well okay it has to be precise
so let's see
howdy looking
yeah all right double-checking Ashish
you go you got it all right let's see
here
Oh another student is ready at the end
he's getting active okay all right very
good
all right why don't you start go
okay okay
sheesh
I'm asking you go one more move you had
to go a friend one more move and win
okay now Ruchi for is a mate you got
everything except the last hope and it's
actually the same concept is also if it
goes here okay
it's same concept it doesn't change he
goes here now with rook g4 mate if you
go 94 rook takes if it was 92 what do
you do
Queenie - yes and he takes
so group before
now night eat ooh
so Bishop III we got Bishop III we just
bring the rook over and it's made on g4
so rocketry it appears to be a little
bit more challenging okay it's the
winning of course but look before and
then later they don't even give up to
give this idea but okay it's like Bishop
b6 or something exceed maybe yes Queen
c5 it's just quickly check I'm sure that
we're missing something here yeah so I
guess we're not missing same thing so
they just didn't give up the bishop so
the key is to keep the bishop bishop a7
okay they just don't have this a move
defense here rook before 92 it's a very
special defense because now a night goes
on g3 but you just keep the pressure by
playing the bishop here okay with ideas
like rook h4 and even take this guy it's
not like winning easily but it's still
winning because you're not going to be
able to do much about this pin here so
rook rookie 4 is a huge threat here
so you're gonna have to play like 93 to
prevent that and now attack another
attack here the key is to eliminate this
Bishop and if he goes here now
disconnect the communication g5 and now
there should be three this game over
okay a little bit deeper you have to go
and find the difficult move Bishop a7
okay but after Bishop a7 there is really
no defense
White is just totally tied up you know
he cannot do anything so here attack
here attract and disconnect the bishop
all right great job guys and thank you
everybody for coming to this class and
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]